reese witherspoon run announcer back in
2006 for a role as a country music star
June Carter Cash and walk the line
remember that on Sunday she might add a
couple of Emmys to her collection of
awards she's one of four women including
Nicole Kidman and shailene woodley
nominated for their performances in the
HBO series big little lies it's so good
where this one is also producer of this
critically acclaimed show CBS News
contributor and Vanity Fair executive
West Coast editor Christus
spoke with her at the new dream Hotel in
Hollywood and you join us at the table
welcome Krista welcome hi good morning
well a lot of us know Reese Witherspoon
for her bubbly portrayals of perky
characters but there's a lot more to
this actress who's become one of the
most powerful women in show business
she's a producer a businesswoman and a
vocal proponent for other women
navigated the complicated currents of
Hollywood
the mothers of Monterrey are the Belles
of the ball at this Sunday's Emmy Awards
so nice Thank You Monterrey we pound
people with knives to this the darkly
comic HBO series about maternal mischief
and murder among a group of coastal
California women is up for 16 awards
including one for star Reese Witherspoon
same five women who are so dynamic and
complex on film I think was fascinating
to people
well I'm Madeline Martha McKenzie I
always say the Martha but no one calls
me that they call me Madeleine why did
you pick Madeleine well I didn't pick
mal and Allen picked me david kentley
the writer called me one day he'd
written in a script and I was like yeah
but I don't know who's gonna play
Madeleine he's like you're playing
Madeleine it's like what are you talking
about
he's like you are Madeleine do you sir
Jenna husband er
I should be soon boyfriend girlfriend
I'm open to all possible but I'm not a
busybody at all I'm just very interested
in other people's lives
Chrissa is that so wrong she's trying to
be helpful
you're southern I'm southern we're
friendly I'm not more of that that
feeling
she's also real powerful besides
starring in the show she also produces
it a role she transitioned to when she
formed her production company in 2012
and started acquiring the rights to
popular books so I was already a
voracious reader and I just ended up
buying books like gone girl in Wilder my
first two that I bought I had no idea I
bought him with my own money
I still funded a company for five years
so what are we going with saying Johnny
you got me out here is that where you're
playing in
she made the move after she won an
Academy Award for playing June Carter
Cash and walked the line where's my
friend John gonna get hi Rosie incognito
I was gone and then fell into a post
Oscar slump there was one moment where I
read this script that came in and my
agent sent it to me and it was just
awful and I called my agent I said I'm
not gonna do this who would want to do
this he said every actress in Hollywood
wants this part and it was just a
lightbulb moment for me that I I thought
I have to do better and I have to create
more and do better for other women and
create opportunity
for other women you change the course of
your career basically I don't see women
at the center of their own movies as
much as I would like to do you feel like
you're finally taken seriously yeah I
mean I notice people return my phone
calls quicker and it's it's great it
feels like this is what I'm supposed to
be doing hi I'm Elle Woods and this is
freezer woods and we're both Gemini
vegetarians but that doesn't mean the
actress who created unforgettable
characters like Elle Woods in Legally
Blonde
and Tracy Flick an election is giving up
her time in front of the camera did you
watch this I did but only because I was
general odden she's revisiting familiar
romantic comedy territory in her latest
film home again and then it's time for a
highly anticipated reunion with her big
sister from friends Jennifer Aniston the
pair will reteam for an upcoming series
about the world of morning television
you really think that's gonna work on me
I invented that right one of the great
things but just forgetting to work
together again we're not like over the
moon we keep texting each other that's
so fun I can't believe we're doing this
and it's based on morning news shows yes
and I it's not lost on me that we're on
a morning news show and it's just great
to talk about women's role in media and
how women are treated on the Morning
News and what that journey is like
Witherspoon's journey is also taken her
into business as the driving force
behind the women's lifestyle brand
Draper James it's named for your
grandmother named doctor my grandmother
Dorothy Draper yeah my grandma is my
biggest inspiration she was one of first
women to graduate from Peabody with a
teaching degree in 1941 and it was just
a little bit hard for her I think
because there weren't a lot of jobs for
women at that time and you were expected
to stay home particularly in the south
and I feel like in some ways I'm kind of
getting to live the life that she didn't
get to live and when everyone's leaning
away from retail you just leaned in
sometimes you just have to jump two feet
into a cold pool
and then just figure out how to swim
later Witherspoon has definitely become
a very strong swimmer and she's sewing
showing no signs of slowing her pace and
everybody is asking about a second
season for big little lies but that
depends on the author Layne Moriarty to
continue the stories of these remarkable
women I love everything about Reese
where there's material you did it for 60
minutes
she's so sunny so sparkly and so smart
and so smart especially smart I mean her
accompanist right there now trying to
find and be a bitter on any good book
that's that's in the process of being
released yeah that's right that's
awesome
she's great we vote thumbs up for big
little eyes I loved it
good luck to Reese on Sunday night
Christa thank you so much